[Music]
hey it's think story and you're probably
wondering how i got here
i was not expecting that if you like
dinosaurs and everything wrong with
movies you'll love jurassic hunt
the movie so bad it made me question how
it was even made yeah but your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think if they should so come
along with me as i take a look at this
giant pile of dino dung and make sure to
like and subscribe because welcome to
jurassic hunt you son of a [ __ ] well
you know the movie's gonna be good when
it's made by dazzler we're someplace so
top secret that the 12 hunters who have
paid for the privilege of hunting down
these prehistoric predators have to wear
burlap sacks i can't breathe in this
thing how much further is it we're close
and they go through all this trouble to
keep its location a secret but forget to
take off the colorado license plates
this place is a dump you got that right
random guy who gets eaten in the first
10 minutes this is jurassic hunt where
no expense is spared even on the logo
and as dr hammond says his famous line
in jurassic park welcome
to jurassic park so too does our park
operator lyndon welcome to jurassic hunt
we'll get a little bit more into lyndon
in a bit he's well uh he's a character
you like to watch don't you
yeah you do i nearly vomited because of
the top secret nature of this place
every hunter has to sign ndas and agree
to no communication with the outside
world which means no cell phones really
convenient when [ __ ] starts to hit the
fan and in some sort of hunger games
like fashion each hunter is allowed to
choose their own weapon this is where we
meet our film's protagonist parker an
undercover agent working to expose the
park for its crimes against animals of
all the weapons she could choose she
opts for a tranquilizer gun because
she's vegan and doesn't believe in
hurting anyone the world could always
use another vegan the rules for the hunt
are simple you are allowed to shoot
anything that was allowed 65 million
years ago you only keep what you can
carry there's even a fun hint that the
animals here at jurassic hunt are
shipped in from the quote-unquote big
park linking jurassic hunt with jurassic
park nobody cares and for a place that's
supposed to be top secret they even have
these funky themed water bottles well
let's meet some of the other hunters
comprised of some of the worst racial
stereotypes you can imagine first
there's blackhawk an african pirate
warlord wanted by the fbi cia and
interpol then i've killed the biggest
thing on earth well
the second biggest thing just uh
threw up at my mouth a little bit and
what about torres oh i'm going to love
gutting that little panejo or the
redneck named [ __ ] who just came here
to [ __ ] the dinosaurs you ever when you
see them you know get get those like
urges parker's plan to expose the park
for its crimes against animals and now
humans revolves around her glasses which
contain a hidden recording device if she
can show the world what's going on maybe
she can shut down the park and hold its
owners accountable but first she'll have
to survive the constant onslaught of
dinosaur attacks realizing that the
jurassic hunters
have become the jurassic hunted this
place is insane the first night on the
reserve goes to hell in a handbasket
when the group is surrounded by a flock
of raptors
luckily this dude's brought a rocket
launcher rocket launcher who the hell
says the name of their weapon before
firing it he's promptly killed the
aftermath of the attack is pretty
gruesome with this initial group of 12
dropping to six meanwhile at the
breeding facility linden is informed of
the deaths but has other things on his
mind come on breed already unlike
jurassic park where breeding is done via
dna in these pristine labs here it's in
some shitty barn i do like however this
shot where a random dude is casually
bathing a dinosaur in the back as if
dinosaurs that are gonna be killed need
to be bathed while making their way to
their first checkpoint [ __ ] is hit with
acid from a dilophosaurus and yes i had
to look up what that dinosaur was called
it's pretty funny because the first
thing everyone says is not to touch it
but what does he do do not touch it
help me get off he gets attacked in the
face and somehow drops a grenade and
almost gets everyone killed the team
ends up making it to the first
checkpoint where somehow this guy has
access to fresh frozen ice cream bars
and blackhawk uses this opportunity to
wax poetic about how he killed a [ __ ]
ton of american soldiers while in africa
that's how he got his nickname he shot
down a blackhawk helicopter and if any
of you have seen deep blue c minor
spoiler head it's just like that scene
where sam jackson's character is doing
this rousing speech but is then suddenly
eaten by a shark the same thing kinda
happens here but blackhawk is attacked
by a pterodactyl black [ __ ] comes out on
top
blackhawk
now i'm no physicist but this
pterodactyl is picking up at least 250
pound man
[ __ ] now you know lyndon is
really taking seriously the fact that
his hunters are dying one by one because
he's spending his time watching movies
on his phone fun fact the movie he's
watching is the classic snake out of
compton made by the same director as
jurassic hunt averaging a slightly
higher score of 2.9 out of 10 on imdb he
finds out that parker is really a spy by
reading her profile something you'd
think he should have done before
inviting her to the hunt [ __ ] and
sergey decide to go on their own where
they shoot a little baby dino and this
is one of my biggest complaints of the
movie but the characters never seem to
hear these giant dinosaurs sneaking up
on them did you hear that oh man i hear
nope
there's also this guy named rabbit who
works for linden he's got himself
trapped in the reserve and linden tasks
him with taking out the hunters he does
this by spraying parker with this
canister of green goo which is dinosaur
hormones to attract the raptors what the
heck just happened but really it's just
an excuse to get her to take off her
jacket and expose her jugs look anything
that got spray on it you gotta get rid
of it right
the hunters also take out their
microchips which linden has been using
to track them throughout the park the
remaining three hunters decide to make
their way to checkpoint two but now that
they know they're also being hunted by
both dinos and linden they have to be
extra cautious they're attacked by a
rogue raptor and i like the cg raptor
doesn't really resemble the prosthetic
one the hunters end up capturing rabbit
hoping he can guide them to linden but
they're so stupid that they fall asleep
during the night and he just gets up and
escapes earlier that night torrez
randomly gives parker some dog tags
we'll find out what these are for later
but in the moment i was like where did
he get these and who is henry braxton
the name on the tags so i went through
the end credits to find that there are
no characters by that name but the
director's name is hank braxton so
there's that i guess on their way to
checkpoint 2 we get another one of those
scenes where our raptor completely
sneaks up on them and bites valentine in
the arm there's still a mission for you
to complete soldier understand you might
have also noticed that the color seems
to change here it's like they decided to
shoot one part of the scene at sunrise
and the other late in the day and for
those of you who are very astute you'll
notice snow on the ground here they've
gone from what appeared like scorching
savannah-esque planes to snow on the
ground hey i haven't visited colorado
before so who knows taurus goes off
chasing that raptor and starts kicking
these little baby raptors or at least i
think they are because the mama raptor
comes after him and he doesn't have any
arrows left so he just uses his bow as a
weapon to take on the raptor now it's
implied that he's dead we never actually
see him get killed but they're probably
just leaving us in suspense for jurassic
hunt too parker reveals to valentine
this guy here that she's a spy so you
are a spy i'm with an agency that's
trying to expose this place in its
cruelty and as they make it to the
second checkpoint they're held at
gunpoint by lyndon and his thug riggs
didn't your father ever teach you never
to strike a woman but if you do you beat
her to the body so the bruises won't
show riggs ends up destroying parker's
spy glasses which contain all the
footage of these atrocities
nerd what is this grade 2 he's wearing
glasses as well lyndon tells her that no
one will care about what's going on in
the park he has lineups of billionaires
celebrities and politicians just waiting
to get in remember those dog tags well
parker uses them to reflect sunlight
into a nearby pterodactyl who then goes
insane and attacks riggs and if that
wasn't convenient enough at the same
time a raptor attacks forcing linden
into the brush he calls her back up and
a team of special guards come to his aid
they don't bring a helicopter or a
vehicle or anything like that they just
decide to come in on foot no idea why
and quickly this goes to hell in the
most coordinated dinosaur attack ever
caught on film simultaneously two
t-rexes multiple raptors those
acid-spitting dinos and pterodactyls
attacked the team leaving only linden
alive this guy survives everything one
dude even tries to hide up a tree i have
no idea what he's thinking meanwhile
parker's made it to the park's exit
after valentine saved her life by
distracting a group of raptors away from
her the exit to this multi-million
dollar operation is of course locked
with a 10 padlock from home depot a
padlock key which is held by lyndon and
in the final confrontation parker
demands the key from lyndon he gives it
up and in what is quite possibly the
stupidest moment in the whole film she
leaves her gun on the ground while she
tries to unlock the padlock allowing
linden to grab the gun and flip the
tables on her i can't believe you're
that stupid yeah me too then as if on
cue two raptors appear out of nowhere
parker punches linden in the dick grabs
the gun and escapes leaving linden to be
eaten alive now thankfully a truck is
conveniently located outside the
compound with its keys readily available
but who decides to show up it's
valentine who has survived his battle
with the raptors and somehow was able to
escape the two drive off into the
distance to live happily ever raptor now
if you thought this movie was bad you
gotta check out my worst tv shows and
movies playlist which i've left a link
to in the comments and end card it is
some videos that make this film look
like the godfather thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you